hey guys Pete here in my video the other
day I talked about the new history and
lore clip that was circulating around
it's a promo for the season 6 DVDs
release today I'm gonna talk about that
and how it's related to brand story
going forward and his purpose in the end
of the series this video is mostly
speculating about already known facts
but could have some spoilers if you
aren't caught up with the TV show
through season 6 make sure you stick
around to the end of this video to learn
how you can win a copy of the 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
the book now let's get started if you're
not familiar with the history and lore
clips for the DVD sets the short clips
that discuss different bits of history
from the Song of Ice and Fire books that
don't get fully addressed in the show
they're cool way to learn things if you
haven't read the books and for book
readers they're also fun to watch
because they're animated and they're
really well put together anyways they
release the first one early with the
list of the other 17 that will be
included with the DVD set the one we're
talking about today is titled the
children of the forest versus the first
men and it's narrated by Max von Sydow
who played the three-eyed Raven it's an
old story that I think most people know
but they also added a couple minor
things based on show canon which is why
I decided to make the video really quick
I'll explain the conflict between the
children and the first men if you want
to know more details go watch the clip
or read about it on you know Westeros
org or read the section in the world of
Ice and Fire book before the first men
the children of the forest reigned
supreme on the continent of Westeros it
was basically just them and Giants who
lived there and even though they fought
each other from time to time neither
side really cared to dominate the
continent there weren't that many
children or Giants so there was no
urgency for resources or land and things
like that then about 12,000 years before
the current events that we see in
Westeros right now the first men arrived
from Essos they traveled across the land
bridge that connected the two continents
which was called the arm of Dorne the
first men were different in that they
built huts and villages and to do this
they had to cut down trees and they burn
and cleared land and all that stuff this
was in direct conflict with the children
who worship trees so they declared war
on the men to clash of cultures
basically the children live in harmony
with the land for the most part and have
a small footprint as far as things go
the first man have large numbers in the
farm they clear land to make space for
this and they build dwellings which
takes up a lot of resources the two
things don't mix and it's basically the
same as the story of Europeans calling
colonizing the United States the native
people who live there for what seemed
like forever suddenly found there wasn't
enough room for them in their own land
much in the same way that the Native
Americans tried to fight back against
the Europeans the children of the forest
declared war on the first men but there
was a big problem because the first men
had a technical technological advantage
they had weapons they made out of bronze
leather and shields and they also wrote
horses the children had arrows and
Spears made of dragonglass which weren't
very effective against the first men
shields and their armor was made of
woven bark which was no match for their
bronze swords so the first men were
bigger and stronger with a clear
advantage in weaponry the children were
losing the war and at the same time they
were losing the only home they ever knew
unlike the Native Americans who suffered
that exact fate in this world there's
magic and that was one category where
the children had a clear advantage it
said through the magic of the green
seers they destroyed the arm of Dorne in
the south and tried to do the same in
the neck to cut off the first men from
traveling north they failed in their
attempt to split Westeros and to which
only succeeded in flooding the neck
creating bogs and swamps and stuff like
that this is something that's always
been referred to as legend but in the
clip it talks about it as there are you
know their actual events that happen
eventually the two sides made a pact
that brought about 4000 years of peace
the children gave up all the lands of
Westeros besides the deep woods and in
return the first men agreed not to cut
down any more weirwood trees this led to
the Age of Heroes were what things
basically went well for both sides the
men adopted the children's godswood
are now referred to as the old gods and
they even started carving faces into the
weirwoods creating heart trees the
children taught them some of their magic
and taught them how to use Ravens to
communicate over long distances in those
days the Ravens would actually speak the
message and the greenseers of the
children would change their skins to
speak through the birds when the others
came during the long night the first men
and the children had to join forces this
is a whole other story which we know
ended with the Nights Watch being formed
in the wall being built that's pretty
much the short version of the story
which the history and lore clip adds
more detail to what stands out about the
clip though is that it adds in some
parts that aren't usually associated
with the story they're not unknown or
anything but it caught me when I was
watching that they were added to the
story and it was probably on purpose
they mentioned the things from the world
of Ice and Fire like that the greenseers
used the animals like dire wolves and
shadowcats and all that then they added
that the children believe that the first
men weren't only cutting down weirwood
trees but when they saw what happened
they didn't see white stumps they saw
their ancestors who were now lost
forever it says that the first men
didn't know that the children believed
that their spirits entered the trees
after they died it goes on that the
children didn't have any letters of
runes so all of their history songs and
prayers only the trees remembered that
stuff this isn't exactly new information
but most of it could actually be deduced
from reading the entire series but it is
new in relation to the story of their
motivation in the story the story of the
children versus the first men in the
world book it doesn't include this
expressly and it doesn't include the
next bit at all since it's something
that's only been revealed in the show
thus far clip talks about the
desperation the children experienced and
how they look to their green seers for
help as mentioned it says they broke the
arm adorned which isn't necessarily
necessarily considered true by the
maesters but it talks about it as fact
and then it adds fearing extinction the
children combine their powers for one
last spell that would save their people
and their land from the invaders by
themselves the children were too few to
stop the onslaught
but if they could turn men's numbers
against them it just trails off there
after confirming when the children
created the White Walkers we learned
that in show Canaan at least that the
children created the White Walkers as a
last-ditch effort to save their people
and their lands there's no evidence that
this had any effect on anything though
since it goes on to tell the story of
the pact that ended the war it just says
after hundreds of year years of war the
wisest of both sides met on the Isle of
faces and the gods eye to make peace it
doesn't mention the order of green men
which is a bummer as far as I'm
concerned because that's something I've
always hoped that we would eventually
get to see in this part of the story but
after that it shows brand and it says
that after the dawn must come the night
the great evil that the children
unleashed in the world returned
centuries later only an alliance between
the children and men could stop it again
not new information but in this context
leads to some foreshadowing in my
opinion it wraps things up by saying
that now it comes again
referring to the White Walkers when the
children are just a shadow of what they
once were and men have long forgotten
but the trees remember and Brandon Stark
must learn or as we watch the first men
so will we watch the last so I think
these small changes are some pretty
important stuff there are many theories
about brands role in the end of the
story but this clearly ties it to him
learning what needs to be done to save
humanity and the war to come if you
watch my brand in the three-eyed Raven
video you know that I think he's always
been set up to play a crucial role and I
think that this back side up ever since
the hold the door episode there have
been countless theories about brand
time-traveling and being all these older
brand Starks or whatever that I've never
been on board with first if that was his
purpose in the story what does this have
to do with what's going on right now is
there some connection with him realizing
this and somehow that helps Westeros
understand how to win the war for the
dawn to me it makes a lot more sense
that he draws on the information that
the trees have to learn what needs to be
done in the books the three-eyed crow
tells him that he uses the trees to see
but eventually will be able to look far
beyond that and
show we've seen this happen he's able to
see John's birth without a tree in sight
and this is something that the
three-eyed Raven led him to there are a
lot of interesting theories about what
the weirwoods are and what they
represent this clip tells us that the
children's history and basically all
they've known or were is contained
inside they're the most popular theories
about them talk about the weirwood net
which is not just a connection that
exists through their roots being
physically connected under the ground
but depending on what you read could be
a collective unconscious the detailed
collection of important information or
even a sinister hive mind that would
sound pretty far out there if george RR
martin hadn't written sci-fi books with
similar themes all that is theory though
he could talk about it for days since it
is actually fun to think about but with
this history and lore clip we have some
clues as to what the show wants us to
know about the children and brands
importance to the end of the story there
are still big questions like why did it
take the White Walkers so long to become
a threat and where the children just
bound by their pact with men so that
when the attack came they decided to
fight against the others or did they
realize that their creation was out of
control to the point that it wouldn't
just destroy the men but that the
children would be wiped out along with
the rest of the world in the process I
want to point out one passage from the
first book that hints at brands purpose
long before he arrived north of the wall
to meet the three-eyed raven face to
face he had this dream when he was in
his coma back in Winterfell and he
looked past the wall past endless
forests cloaked in snow past the frozen
shore and the great blue-white rivers of
ice and the dead plains were nothing
grew or lived north and north and north
he looked to the curtain of light at the
end of the world and then beyond that
curtain he looked deep into the heart of
winter and then he cried out afraid in
the heat of his tears burned on his
cheeks now you know the crow whispered
as it sat on his shoulder now you know
why you must live
why bran said not understanding falling
falling because winter is coming this is
only a small part of the dream but it's
particularly important based on
history and lore editions bran travels
to the end of the world and what he sees
there fills him with terror
it goes on Brandon looked at the crow on
his shoulder in the crow look back it
had three eyes and the third eye was
full of terrible knowledge bran looked
down there was nothing below him now but
snow and cold in death a frozen
wasteland where jagged blue-white spires
of ice waited to embrace him they flew
up at him like Spears he saw the bones
of a thousand other dreamers and paled
on their points he was desperately
afraid can a man still be brave if he's
afraid he heard his own voice saying
small and far away and his father's
voice replied to him that is the only
time a man can be brave now bran the
crow urged choose fly or die death
reached for him screaming bran spread
his arms and flew now he wakes up after
this and so you can explain it all the
way if you wanted to to me though it
sounds like he looked into the heart of
winter to see a terrifying threat to
mankind and then came out with the
purpose the clip says the trees remember
and bran must learn or else man will
basically be wiped out blood Raven had
influence over what brand saw in this
dream and we could take the thousands of
other dead dreamers to mean that bran is
being tested by choosing to fly he's
accepting responsibility to play a part
that only he can play so what do you
think about all this do you think that
the slight changes in the clip are put
there as hints how does it fit with the
theories you already had about bran and
his purpose and the story for me it
strengthens my position that he isn't
one of the heads of the Dragon he isn't
being set up as a time traveler that's
all the brendan starts throughout
history and doesn't need the skin change
any dragons for that matter it
reinforces the theory that bran is on
his own path which is separate but equal
to those of the three heads I'd really
like to hear what you guys think though
and maybe I'll make some more videos
about the different brand theories
please like the video if you enjoyed it
and please subscribe to my channel
please follow me on social media
networks by clicking on the links in the
description or my channels main page
also check out some other of my videos
while you're here as mentioned in the
beginning
book giveaway going on when I hit 28,000
subscribers I'll pick one commenter and
send them a copy of the new 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
I'll put an Amazon link in the
description so you can give it a look if
you haven't seen it yet it's really nice
looking and I'll put a link for the DVD
set there too since it's now out and
shipping all you have to do to win the
giveaway is just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video or any
other video where I mentioned this
giveaway to see how I pick the winner
you can check out my Dragonstone video
because at the end of that one I picked
the winner of the last giveaway thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon